folks this just in over the wire we got
a hot new merch drop get back drop baby
from november 8th to november 18th you
can get your limited edition toddy's
goodies we're asking everyone to remain
calm
we're gonna have a real black friday
situation on our hands we got bernie's
teas and hoodies we got hoodies tees we
got hoodies tees and hoodies we got
bunkos we got bonkos tees and hoodies
guys uh the link will be in the
description go to bonfire.com
are you garbage limited edition only
available for 10 or 11 days get them
while they're available get the holiday
orders in now also
not to forget our new york city show's
part of the new york comedy festival at
gotham comedy club on november 9th get
those tickets do it come see us welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts kevin ryan and h foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy cause they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host holy coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here in antony's basement she's off to
tampa for first class or what well she
heard tom brady was handing out bitcoin
so she's going down to get her hands on
it okay i said i think he only does that
for kids that might be sick
and she's like well and i'm like you
don't look sick and she's like yeah but
if i'm an 11 year old i'll look terrible
yeah yeah we'll see how it works out all
right my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me unamused this week
big strikeout on the twitter that was a
long one okay
dude your wheelhouse is short and sweet
i love them there's a part two you gotta
see it next week ladies and gentlemen he
is the ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with in the board room you
can ask the boys at enron that
kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
happy to be here as always please make
sure you rate view subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true to roof
[ __ ] cooking baby
uh and then the greatest website of all
time shout out to al gore for inventing
the internet yes shout out to the yam
family the conte family for
shout out to their parents getting
hopped up and banging and making those
two and and coming up with patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you get
bonus episodes [ __ ] content videos
live shows there's
tons of [ __ ] on there get involved let's
go baby we're going to disney going to
disneyland
i think it's like 300 more people and i
got to take
fatty to disney
i'm fatty because anybody's wondering
and i've got a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire he's the
magic man he makes us all look good he
does the ones and twos give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what up
dudes hey t-bone i'm stoked we got a
chicago legend
talk about making your bones down there
in rosemary
tell these bums what happened gang we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly and i mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time she is a very funny stand-up
comedian actor and podcaster you've seen
her and horace and pete the king of
staten island wow pause with sam jay
adam devine house party oh boy chelsea
lately comedians in public she has two
comedy central half hours you've seen
her on at midnight not safe with nikki
glazer late night with seth meyers this
is not happening funny as hell what's
your [ __ ] deal comedy knockout damn
the degenerates on netflix
lights out with david spade your mom's
house she was one of 2017 varieties top
10 comics to watch she has an amazing
podcast called that's messed up an svu
podcast and a fantastic album all clerk
called litter cheese but the big
question about his mind today is she
garbage she broke the coat hanger when
she came out
that was well constructed by me
give it up for lisa traeger everybody
yeah
i choked on glitter cheese god damn it
really typically choke on cheese
i like the hard stuff myself i love
mozzarella mango that was really nice to
hear thank you sometimes you know i felt
you're watching me i felt pressure i'm
sorry i messed up i just couldn't
believe i've done all that i'm excited
even when you said actor i'm like okay
she gave you the face i'm like oh maybe
some of these aren't right like he was
looking at you you said a couple she's
like what i'm like i don't know maybe
125 episodes of er
we got to the city yeah i know how we
met i remember we met at the green
restaurant no you and i didn't you work
at the greek restaurant i worked in a
greece i had a meeting there with
someone fancy and i think she was a
regular and you were our server wow oh
my god i do remember that yeah that's
right it was you
dan soder and dan saint germain all had
now
i don't know if you'd want to yeah i
meant dan saint-germain and he was like
eating a loaf of bread and he had crumbs
in his hair and i was like i don't
know you guys all had taken meetings
there that was a hot spot cause it was
right around the corner from comedy
central i completely forgot about that
oh then how do you think we know each
other no i'm saying when we got to the
city you were like a huge deal you're
moving and shaking that's all it's
giving you a compliment i know it's cool
i like how you were giving her a
compliment she's like weren't you my
waiter one time
you were like we moved up here we saw
lisa traeger one woman's show you never
more bread please she never brought me
that cider ranch did you
it's a good spot it was yeah i loved
that lady too that you were there with
yeah she has bloodhound like the dogs
with the big ears that flop and i like
that oh yeah yeah yeah very very cool
very cool person in the industry yeah i
was running comedy central a little
while not doing big things loved her she
was always sweet to me she's not
watching right
i loved you yeah
i always gave her ten percent all right
call me we'll do lunch i know a good
spot yes thank you buddy thank you for
coming and sitting with us what is the
origin story of eliza traeger so i was
born in the former soviet union what on
the black sea who says it like that
either i think you're waiting for a
comeback
keep an eye on this kid i don't like the
sound of that i'll tell you why because
i'm russian but it's present-day ukraine
and so sometimes if you say like i'm
from russia and then someone's like no
that's actually in ukraine then you have
to be like i know but i'm not ukrainian
and then so i just i think it's easier
to say former soviet union okay so your
family wasn't from the ukraine we're we
are but we're russian you know like no
one got along we came on religious
asylum okay russian jews so i don't know
you came here
wait so you moved during when it was the
soviet union yes we came um in 90 and i
think the soviet union broke apart in
like 92-93 [ __ ] old-school i like
that yes so then we came here you know
uh we were poor i'm even more
intimidated over here
that's crazy wait why were you guys
living in the ukraine if you weren't
ukrainian if you were right because it
was the soviet union it wasn't ukraine
at the time one thing but it was modern
day ukrainian it's modern day yeah were
your parents from that area do they move
down there from regular russia no i
think they're from around there yeah and
they're
three different kinds of dumb
but i don't know and sometimes people
who like love russia will try to be like
have you read this or do you know that
i'm like i don't need to prove anything
to you no i don't know these things no i
don't have to have a russian nesting
doll tattoo
but people want to do
i'm gonna get one yeah um that's pretty
wild yeah so i have old parents they're
born in 1938 and 1945. whoa your parents
your parents were born in 1938
how older than when they had you my mom
was 700. i can't do math
but it's up there did they give you
confederate money
that's crazy i didn't even get bomb bits
i got batman's foot at birth right um i
refused to go to school no my dad my mom
was 42 and my mom my dad was 50 when i
was born nice wow but they didn't get
married i'd like to hear that because i
haven't had kids yet and i'd like to no
you're a dude you couldn't move to the
ussr you can have children whatever you
want okay
live your dreams don't rush into
anything okay
sorry yeah but then i'm gonna be
sneaking out of the soviet union in the
middle of the night with two little kids
85 years old in modern day ukraine yeah
trying to shake putin what are you
talking about gotta be surprised
wait what uh yeah so that's them oh but
my dad okay so it was actually a wild
week so my parents got married
so in 1987 my parents got married august
22nd and then august like
28th my grandma died and i was born
august 31st okay that's like insane to
me so my mom was like super pregnant
when they got married and they had a kid
and they left they left they left the
they left russia together yeah we left
together how old were you when you left
i was like two years old and i got here
when i was three so this isn't in the
same week because that would have been
that was it no it was like within the
last year pregnant married you're born
grandma dies i know and my dad's just
like so closed off and i want to just be
like
how did you feel that week yeah he's not
i'm assuming he's not the kind of guy to
be like well oh yeah those guys are
right that generations
especially those [ __ ] russians man
they're [ __ ] when they have to do
that he probably got here and was like i
don't want to hear a word at any age
yeah he just is uh really um yeah so you
really get you really got to eat okay
i'm sorry sorry sorry
um yeah he so i do a bit about this now
not to do bits but my dad was going into
heart surgery this summer she's all over
the place and
i told him i loved him before he went to
surgery would not say it back to me
really he smiled i could tell he liked
it but he just wanted to tell he liked
it what does he do for a living or did
he he was a school bus driver wow and he
was really popular
he was super popular like the day before
christmas break so many gifts garbage
bags full of gifts what did he do in
russia he was um like a pe teacher coach
he'd boxed he took photographs he was
kind of like a hot [ __ ]
who like hot i've never heard anybody
describe their dad as a hot [ __ ] he was
like
huge thing
guys got a hammer on them can [ __ ] for
days
something you can swing from
[Laughter]
you're nuts
yeah my mom chased my dad for decades i
would say really yeah and then they had
my sister and then he
still older sister yeah 10 years older
than me wow and he like wouldn't i don't
know he wouldn't settle down no so they
weren't married when this was no they
lived separate he kind of ignored my
sister for months i don't even know if
she knows this my mom got drunk and told
me this but
um so and then one day she ran into him
and was like you have a camera because
they were my mom was poor she was like
you need to take photos of your kid and
also your mom should watch my the child
i'm i'm tired wow and so then that's how
folks we got a winner here today i'll
tell you that right now
talking about hitting the jackpot listen
you got a camera you got to be this
kid's father okay
i don't need child support i need a
babysitter and a couple of a couple of
eight by tens okay
crazy
photo shoots at the playground let's go
i see you walking around town with your
camera
take some pictures of my goddamn kid
well obviously that dick
see the money maker let's go see the
ruble maker come on let's do it
oh man wait was it was the getting i
know you don't remember this was the
getting out dicey um yeah so they had to
do like
[Laughter]
i don't think it was jet blue they
weren't putting delays on you at the
airport i would assume no they had to
take a bus and then they were in austria
for six months yeah you gotta get out of
here you did you were with them yeah but
i don't remember the only memory my
first memory as a human is i fell into
like a koi pound pond fountain in italy
that's pretty classy you're spending
time around a koi pond that's a little
bit of a cat yeah but no they never
bought pizza i mean they had to live in
like an apartment with all these other
immigrant families that were sent over
and we got to america and we had a
really cool volunteer family and they
taught us how to be american that's
awesome
and then we moved to the suburbs my
sister wait were they russian the
volunteer family no
so wait that's how they set you up they
let you live with a family together
we lived in like an apartment burger
[Laughter]
from now on you're bears fans all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
first things first
and the cubbies not socks not a white
sox fan okay sorry
sorry that's pretty cool but i don't
hate the cup so you're starting so
you're starting to know what's going on
or at two years you're two years old i
was confused for a really long time yeah
like who's this family where am i from
why are we living here yeah
why is this guy's dick so bad
he seems like a hot [ __ ]
i know that was no he just like has
youthful photos he's sure he's a
good-looking guy a tight body on him
yeah he looks like jude law there's just
like lots of photos of him out on
donkeys and at the beach like he was
kind of living large like just kind of
doing it yeah it's like a trans am over
there
but i didn't know any of this
but when the notebook came out i like
loved the notebook and then my parents
went to see it my dad came home pissed
and he's like i don't know why you like
that trash and then went upstairs and
then my mom was like he's just upset
because he wanted to marry a girl but
she wasn't jewish and by the way he's
been divorced three times before and i
was like really cool so i knew about it
from the notebook those two seem fun
together
yeah i don't know are they still
together i'm sorry they are and it's
definitely like not an example of what i
want in my life sure no they love each
other they like take care of each other
but um it's like
really traditional gender roles gotcha i
don't really love that gotcha i'm with
you my mom does so much we learn from
our parents what's that she just oh
mom's she just does everything and it's
like you won't even put the plate in the
sink i [ __ ] hate you
yeah my mom does a lot too it's awesome
yeah
it is man it's [ __ ] awesome he's in a
more a little traditional
but did you feel as an adult you didn't
know how to do anything oh he he knows
how to do
nothing that's how i am
nothing
took me an hour to get this can of soda
and it was mine
that's the problem because i'm like a
grown up and i have hard times doing
simple tasks because my mom just did
everything i'll give you i'll give you
that i'll give you that i can't blame my
mom for that but i give you that 100 i
feel you on that yeah i feel you 100 and
i get why they did it you know they
wanted me to chill out because i had to
do so much but i just like
they feel bad about the smuggling over
the water yeah
oh yeah i should show you my little
green card photo it is really cute i'm
so sad yeah wait how long did you live
with this family we didn't live with
them they just would like they would
invite us over they would take us
shopping they would like the burger like
they would just like um help us out they
got my mom or something
they got me like yeah they let us know
how to do amazing
allegiance that's awesome and then my
sister poor she went to like a jew high
school she was like four she was like 13
or whatever she was a [ __ ] too yeah but
she ended up married she's triggered
sporty
holy [ __ ] but she ended up marrying her
high school sweetheart and they met
sophomore year of high school and
they're like 43 now and they really like
each other well you raised so you guys
were raised in a jewish community yeah
so we lived in rogers park like my
sister and i slept in the dining room
you know vibes and then what i don't
know what rogers park is oh it's uh
she's like you know rogers park dining
room bed
it's just a super jewy area of chicago
but close to like where indian people
live too
orthodox
yeah we are not we're russian jews like
that because uh religion wasn't really
allowed you know communism so we like do
the stuff
but we don't we're not like doing the
prayers okay it's like culturally you're
like okay well paul will have the
dinners we'll have the ones so it's more
moderate because i'm just trying to get
a picture you're not in you're not in
like a hardcore jewish community where
like but like what ari was kind of went
through we were not a part of it but
that's where we lived like i have gone
to synagogues or it was separate my
sister went to like she wore skirts to
school okay um but we in the home were
like
yeah
gotcha but my dad you know the closer
you get to death the more religious you
get so he's like he's going
what are we doing uh stairs are we
talking in chicago in the city and
rogers park yeah nice which is like the
bronx maybe it's like super north yes i
like this
old school okay now we're okay
and um yeah it was a one bedroom and
yeah i don't know what to tell you and
then my sister and i slept in the dining
room and bunk beds that would be
something we'd like to do dining room
yeah so then
oh you know what you'll love what
russians do that's [ __ ] up we put rugs
on the wall because like for heat and so
we have rugs on the wall and then you
hang like fun stuffed animals and toys
on it and pins so everywhere we lived we
would have rugs on the wall
with like fun stuff
this is that's
first bunk bed in the dining room
all right so you guys move out of there
yeah and then uh they've been in the
same townhouse in skokie illinois which
is super jewy but diverse too a lot of
pacific islanders indian people there
was a hate crime committed there um a
ricky bird song the basketball coach
from northwestern was shot
uh but i don't i don't know i brought it
up but
that's a hard left dude and that was a
lot of information from bunk beds in the
dining room
you know she's the latest at eleven yeah
jesus christ you know ricky littlefoot
you're like what the [ __ ]
she moves quick
i like how you really gets jew heaven
they got woke real quick
what the [ __ ]
no that's what that's the so this racist
lunatic he went on a racist spree and he
came to skokie on purpose because it's
like the nazis march there the kkk would
come when i was a kid
like after world war ii of the highest
uh population of jews outside of israel
so like it's just kind of like a
chance
people can get away for a weekend
if you're into hate crimes racist
vacation tours
it's like pirillo we got a couple pto
days laying around and the end of the
year is coming up go to sheboygan but a
nice a nice area nice area good
community
yeah i still love going back to skokie i
leveled orchard mall so much outdoor old
orchard mall yeah that's a great i have
one of the questions we asked is what is
the name of the mall well now it's like
westfield you know it's like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but we're talking we're talking
the suburbs of chicago where you're
right outside yeah all right yeah like
the train still comes like a john hughes
movie i'm picturing john hughes yeah so
like the home alone houses they're like
probably like 20 minutes for me or like
the first bueller that class house nice
all right now we got a picture cookie
yeah but we lived in a townhouse and so
but then my sis we each got our own room
and i was so sad i was like really i was
like we have i'm like why wouldn't we
sleep together like she was my older
sister i was so sad and she's like
how much
in the kitchen yeah
i was so sad to have my own room
but um yeah so then and they still live
in that townhouse and my dad's kind of a
hoarder so the basement's his area but
it used to be my area would you do that
what do you mean that was like your room
yeah not my room where was the family
computer
uh the basement basement basement yeah
like mavis beacon i would do like typing
you know speakman
she was like um a black typing teacher
and i would learn how to type fast wait
was she a teacher at your high school no
it was a cd rom
how good do you think we are at this
you know my neighbor deb right
i was talking with your aunt clara the
other day she told us
and it was fun lots of kids my age lived
around us and so like we had like really
traditional american suburban but you
were in a town house were you in a
townhouse community yeah so it's like a
one block
stand alone
yeah but oh but okay so it's a real
shout out
i was talking about one that's like like
a neighborhood listen you know why we
picked it because my sister her
boyfriend lived across the street and
across an alley and my parents didn't
speak english so she picked where we
were gonna live when did you move in
there how old were you when you moved in
um i would say for first grade
so she was 16 and she's like i want to
live here and that's where we live yeah
that happened that much
my sister's best friend growing up was
there were russian immigrants and she
did she picked like
everything she was like we picked the
townhouse we moved to we picked that
like she was like i would just want to
go here and they were like why is that a
cultural thing they just don't know
what's going on the parents it's they're
trying to learn
at 50 or 60 years old so the 16 year
old's a little more adapted yeah she's
like filling out the paper where we're
going to unemployment for the i mean
still we order for them at restaurants
still it's like really um it's fine
that's awesome but they just um
we're confused all the time
but like my i picked out their bedding
like they're they're furniture that's
still in their bedroom i picked it out
and i was a child yeah it's weird i
don't still have that they still have it
yikes
[Laughter]
it's going to come back in the style
pretty soon
kippystamps.comstamps.comstamps.com
gang the holidays are approaching you
don't want to be waiting in line at the
post office like a bazaar
with stamps.com you could do it all from
the comfort of your own home or office
yeah it's easy it lets you compare rates
print labels access all the exclusive
discounts for ups usps services all year
long
uh especially if you have business seeds
you can mail your packages uh letters
everything during the holidays skip the
line no smell no tell it's easy peasy
whether you're running an online
business sidehustlestamps.com saves you
so much time money and stress during the
holidays we send all of our merch out
with stamp stocks we do it's easy peasy
they sent us the the printer the labels
i feel like i'm working you know i feel
like i'm i'm running this big
corporation it's printing out the labels
you're going to buy and sell now boom it
makes you and we have a we have a lot of
uh small business owners that listen to
this side also guys so if you're in the
if you're in the need for it it's it's a
fantastic service uh you save time money
this holiday season with stamps.com sign
up with promo code garbage for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts not
bad set it and forget it just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page and a promo code garbage
one more time stamps.com click the
microphone at the top of the page at a
promo code garbage do it dang this
podcast is brought to you by better help
yes all right if you have something in
your life that's bothering you or
something you want to talk through with
somebody you don't know you don't want
to go to an office you don't want to be
out there in public get on better help
they can help take care of you yeah uh
the big man just started therapy talking
to someone it it helps a lot if you've
never done it
it it's it's game it's a game changer i
for me i really made a turning point in
my life with my family my friends
business the whole nine yards when you
do it gives you another set of eyes on
it you know what i mean sure you're
trying to deal with your own crazy and
someone's on the outside going yo
you're cuckoo try this
and this you can log in anywhere uh
service available for clients worldwide
anytime you can send a message to your
counselor you get a thoughtful response
um it's not a self-help line it's not a
crisis line it's therapy uh better help
want you to start living a happier life
today
visit betterhelp.com garbage that's
betterhelp help and join over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional uh in fact so
many people are using better help
they're hiring in all 50 states special
offer for are you garbage listeners get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com garbage that's ten
percent off your first month at
betterhealth.com
garbage do it
yeah
did you go to what kind of high school
did you go to i went to niles north uh
public high school public high school it
was across the street from the mall i
love that that's like yeah that's real
john hughes
yeah i loved that what uh what was the
what was your mascot
the vikings pretty good it's all right i
like it okay great yeah the vikings i
did freshman i had more sports but i was
a hardcore swimmer and i did theater
hardcore swimmer yeah did theater yeah
varsity swimming team in high school
yeah i broke a jv record no big deal
very nice what were the grades like um i
didn't really care i don't even remember
i'm not good i'm sure
c's i was somewhat like i would just go
through scantron like i just didn't i
was just like abba kadaba just watching
i have things to do did you get into did
you go to college i did i uh wait put a
pin in that hang on i just wanted to see
what i was about to get into okay yeah
what was the what was the s8 what did
you get on the s.a.t um we do act i got
a 22. i don't trust those yeah i don't
know what that is
that's good though it's bad it's i
thought it was out of 24. no it's not
35. it's
they don't do it anymore they don't
really like that's not weighted as high
anymore with the new generation of
children okay everybody have nieces and
nephews you know never get any trouble
in high school
yeah you seem like a rule breaker
yeah but it wasn't even cool stuff i was
just a rebel late
to homeroom all the time yeah so i had a
lot of saturday and i had a lot of
absences and [ __ ] so did you have a whip
did you have a car in high school
no no carnage no took the bus uh my mom
would drive me okay and pick me up maybe
i don't know how i got home but your dad
was a bus driver did your mom work over
here yes she was an accountant at a
company for like nursing homes okay and
she worked in a cubicle she worked hard
and she has my personality and she got
into a lot of fights at work and it was
it's pretty fun but i like visiting her
dad was a bus driver all the way through
yes so you guys were to your devices
when you got home from school
what you guys were by yourself yes yes
yes sorry
i was like what devices
making car or something yeah i was home
alone but i'd go home i'd make a
celestia well high school's different
because i was on swim team we practice
in the morning and gotcha okay but
elementary school you go home and go
celeste pizza make a celeste pizza and
then we would all go outside of course
yeah and i still crave it sometimes yeah
and that family really did a number on
you guys
yeah you didn't have the rockefeller
showing you how to be american come home
from school microwave is celeste pizza
watch ronald reagan movies for two hours
no yeah power rangers i really loved but
um yeah and then all the kids would play
outside gotcha and i would ride bikes
and [ __ ] all right that's all pretty
yeah i had katie gary benji that was
like the main crew
what's the name of the grocery store
your mom went to we went to jewel oscar
[Laughter]
now listen can i can i say something
even though it's early in the game yeah
yeah
she's bonkers no bonkos
i'm not seeing
pretty classy so far bunk beds dining
room that's it we we always said that
that doesn't count that's an immigrant
situation they're coming over here
they're starting out that's the best
they can do they're going to jewel oscar
the mom's eating an accountant yeah i
mean for a while
come on they ain't going down to
mariano's
but we didn't have marianas i mean we
did go to aldi and it really humiliated
me for a long time but then once we were
in skokie we were a jewel oscar family
you think aldi's bad i used to be really
embarrassed about it really yeah i was
like for poor people and i would like
try to hide the labels and stuff when i
was a kid huh my mom goes to aldi now
for celebrities yeah well aldi is
different now yeah it's like trendy now
oh really my brother-in-law loves it and
for his birthday i got him i found him
um a quarter holder that was knitted um
an aldi the aldi logo so you can have a
little quarter key chain they were doing
that back then too with this
recently for his bro yeah oh yeah always
quarters really yeah so i got it for him
and he was like i can't wait to post
this on my
aldi facebook group and he's like
yikes he loves all sister got his sister
got herself a winner huh no he is he's
actually like um real all-american guy
there
sounds like a real treat this one
it's his happy place like he goes alone
to aldi and he loves to he's really good
at poker
there's no bars in his area or
bowling alleys yeah he's got a
skateboard i like to go to the
supermarket to cool off for a little
while and that guy's gonna kill people
okay
they got the beans came in today
[Laughter]
just bothered bothering guys on a
loading dock ah new chex mix huh jerry
god damn it dude i told you i'm at work
get out of here
nah that's nice
that's great
and my sister lives three blocks away
from my parents right now nice gotcha
what does she do she is a teacher at a
jewish school okay and then he does like
i don't know tech computer project
management that's good they do good they
do good yeah they have a house and uh
one of their kids just went to college
another two are still there yeah i think
they're doing good okay now what is the
college situation with you okay it was a
little bit of an eye roll there it
wasn't an eye roll it was just so i went
to iowa state okay
for advertising okay and then switched
to sociology and then i unfortunately
did get arrested twice in one month for
what being a drunk [ __ ]
[Laughter]
tax evasion what do you think yeah i
know it wasn't white collar i was asking
it was probably a [ __ ] b or something
sure he beat up a cop at a fraternity
house i did i shoved as an officer oh my
god
i shoved an officer oh man
we're too good
or that was too obvious yeah
for sure
what were you drinking in these days
so the first arrests i don't know
like what was the go to like you say i
where i was staying i was staying iowa
state university all right so big
football school which is a big campus i
got a i got kicked out of the first
football game i went to
as a freshman
she had an interception too
i was having a good game
his [ __ ] wouldn't let me shine
let me be great too too much celebrating
in the end zone you know what i mean
boys
oh my god what'd you get kicked out for
i was just wait i just was wasted i
think i took my skirt off or something
[Laughter]
i was kind of why i did a drink i was
like wild i don't know i really partied
were you like one of those girls you
would like could you be like chug it
like drinking out of like a bottle of
jack or were you like i clearly couldn't
do that
no we what we would do and even up until
my early 20s my i like we would play
circle of death with a bottle of vodka
so we'd get like um a handle of vodka
and then like whatever girls we were
with we would drink it yeah yeah yeah in
a circle and then go out
oh damn yeah so i was vodka i think
throughout call it but then the second
arrest we chugged parrot bay the rum
yeah that's what
i'm like captain morgan man myself well
i wasn't proud of it sure i have don't i
don't think they sell that at like
drugstores
yeah
gotta go to jules yeah oh i love jungle
juice like that was always fun i feel
like
have you ever made your own jello shots
um
no
but i have soaked gummy bears no i don't
like to do stuff so like
we had to do the fraternity you made a
[ __ ] one of those jello shots is too
much out like it's a lot of work yeah i
don't need that
no i agree
i've uh hosted things with other people
and they've taken care of the jello shop
sure arrested twice in college yes so
then i had to draw so i had to go home
and then i went to what year are we
talking uh sophomore year sophomore year
i went home
and then i
had a lot of fun i work i was a
receptionist at a hair salon and i loved
it it's really living in your parents
sit living with my parents you do have
very receptionists at a hairline energy
yeah yeah probably
probably real sweet but if somebody gave
you attitude it was going to be a
problem yeah i took care of my girls you
know
i'm mother goose in this [ __ ] okay
wait who are your girls the people who
treat me like if i i could squeeze in an
appointment i could find something i'll
change a lunch break like i will get
you the most money that you can make
like i really am passionate about salon
receptioning and i did it for a long
time okay at a few different salons i
think like if everything fails
go back and do that i think so it
wouldn't be a lot of money but that's
like what i that's what i'm good at i
enjoy it yeah yeah um
what oh yeah that's what you think your
specialty is yeah the software the
millennium salon software they might
have they might have upgraded that since
your time in the in the trenches no
because i remember i started working at
a new salon and i was training and then
i was asking such intricate questions
and they were like you don't have to
train you seem stellar and i was like
yeah okay i can make appointments so
salon receptionist yeah
okay and then i went to columbia college
which is not really like where's that at
i'm sorry it's like the one in the city
here no not columbia university
i can't believe i'm being laughed at
like this it's like a college it's in
chicago it's like um it's like um
right next to portillo's it's a [ __ ]
fake school yeah it's a fake school it's
um
it's like a community an artsy community
college so you can go into like music
production don't feel bad this man was
homeschooled yeah he was homeschooled i
wasn't home i just didn't go to middle
school it's different yeah see yeah yeah
so columbia just a semester
to get my feet wet i'm trying to stick
up for you
i know she's trash so i lasted there for
three weeks and then well i went into
music business and i'm truly tone deaf
what did you really think like music you
thought you were gonna be like the next
dr dre like what was it i thought i was
gonna like work at the metro like i
thought i was gonna work at a venue i
don't know i like wanted to work at a
venue but i'm tone deaf i'm true these
guys are awesome huh
that's a trash truck
so that was like a weird moment in life
and i also had a suspended life since i
was like taking the truth from what
for that first arrest i was drinking and
driving i actually take a greyhound bus
back to iowa and serve two days um in
jail and that i am upset yeah but i have
a smart core it's a bad remake of good
fellas take me to jail to a [ __ ] bus
driver yeah also columbia college has an
acceptance rate of 90 yeah everyone can
go and then but my next college gets
worse so then some more college yeah i i
ended up graduating i graduated you know
from my parents i do have a lot of like
immigrant guilt like i really have to
like do good or something but
i went to north park university it's on
the north side of chicago and it's a
christian evangelical swedish covenant
college and i went there to be a gym
teacher a lot of adjectives
what the hell was their mascot
say that one more time all the way
through
what was their mascot i don't know but
this is a meatball on the cross
they suck
took me a second so that's a good piece
of business
wait so you want to be a gym you're all
over the map
[Laughter]
gym teacher hair salon one of the two
majors at iowa state advertising and
sociology you shoot for the stars though
i'll tell you that
i'll give you that i don't know gym
teachers a little she really went
slumming it i know it was weird but i
was just like you know i'll get summers
off and then so i just went there
because my my favorite gym teachers went
there gym teacher would be awesome oh
yeah yeah especially in like a good
school in a good area those guys make
cash yeah yeah it just wasn't my passion
obviously and then i did find stand up
at 21 while i was there at college so
then i um switched to sociology
and just like finished it out while
waitressing and doing stand-ups were you
living at home at the time
yeah i lived at home most the time i did
comedy and then i had a i lived in the
city for a bit and then i just like went
back home so that's nice you can get
back and forth from your mom's your
parents house to the to the city to do
your thing yeah that's right and stand
up yeah and i had a car and that's why
when people [ __ ] about la traffic or
like oh that's far i'm like i'm just
kind of used to driving like a half hour
40 minutes what was that car
i had a oh i had a cute car i had a
nissan versa hatchback and i really
loved it
kippy anything on that yeah hatchbacks
are never good i was like you take that
hatchbacks are bad news i've never heard
of the verses
oh i've rented that really yeah that's
one that's like when you go like give me
the account it's not a maxima no it
looks like a roller skater
i loved it yeah no i've driven versus a
lot of times it's typically what you get
when you rent a car they're like you'll
get like the nissan versa or something
similar yeah i drive a center now oh
that's nice
i'm a kia man myself really it was the
only they were my car my credit's so bad
it was the only people that would give
oh wow okay
yeah so then that's it and then i go
well my friend who's still my best
friend now um she works at that college
and i had three more credits and i would
have to do another semester and she
worked in student records and she
changed stuff so i got to graduate
so then i got to do a surprise
graduation because my um and so my
sister was like we're going to you
really did it right you didn't have
enough hours i did it just [ __ ] up
with all the transfers not everything
transferred and she did believe in her
heart that i deserve to graduate
so do i and she showed a lot of
ingenuity setting up that scam
so zip it you yeah throwing your file in
a fire we got pictures from the
graduation party all right she graduated
yeah i graduated and then i surprised my
parents so my sister's like we're going
to a russian concert and then took him
to the mcdonald's by the college and
then i showed up in a cap and gown and
they were really happy at mcdonald's
just across the street and then i got to
graduate and they were really happy did
they then go to the graduation ceremony
with you yes okay so it was the
graduation ceremony for that college
yeah the northern christians yeah
swedish pizza place non-denominational
yeah um
so you found out so they thought you
weren't going to graduate they just were
worried you know i cause i also got
arrested a third time at that point
would you they had plans for the day on
the day of graduation to go somewhere
else they were gonna okay so you weren't
graduating they no they thought my
sister was in on the scam and so she
said they're going to a russian concert
yeah
that's cute yeah and you had to change
the grades that surprised your parents
grades just credits just making credits
sure
and then i loved sociology and then um
and then i just that's it and then i've
just been doing stand up and like uh you
know a waitress then there was a backup
nanny and i've been full-time for a
little bit
it's quite the tail yeah it's a [ __ ]
yeah
do you guys ever go home now do you does
your
does your parents still have family in
modern day ukraine no they have some
friends
and like my hat like
there's like an ex-wife there my mom has
a grandkid there and it's like yeah
but they're trying to help her she's
burying herself well yeah should i um
basically no there are some friends and
uh my sister's gone back my parents have
no interest of going back at all okay
and like i don't really love russian
people like
nervous
i don't want you coming in
yeah they're just like i would be scared
i would be scared i don't want to be
there like sure now i'm with you
like jews like i want to eventually go
but i'm not in a rush to like run to
putin's uh do you speak russian yeah
fluently yeah but like i wouldn't be
able to go to college but i could talk
to people that are you know
do you speak any other languages no
russian is pretty hard though that's
pretty much a tough one she speaks two
languages kippy yeah yeah i'm glad i
feel like this
went to 15 different colleges all right
arrested nine times soda roadster she
needed to get her to take what she wants
to get a well-rounded education what do
you want yeah sociology and gym teacher
well that's why when people are like oh
do your immigrant parents like feel like
what do they think about comedy i'm like
they were like relieved they were so
happy that i found comedy because i was
just like out of control and then i was
all focused and then they just knew
where i was that's awesome it's awesome
yeah so they were really happy okay i
love it yeah all
right is it too quiet no no no this is
where we shift into like the proper
uh where do you live now are you living
in the city no i live in highland park
in l.a okay i was living in the main
residence yeah right now and you said
you had the car i haven't yeah i leased
a car
nice
solo do you have roommates i live alone
live alone yes not too shabby rent or
own i've i rent okay
yes i run okay um
hmm what's the credit score like in the
700s pretty good yeah how many credit
cards do you have
um
it's just one right now just uh for
delta miles okay mx no max
yeah i have that but my yeah i'm pretty
good now and i try not to get into
trouble but my big thing was i love
getting no interest for one year credit
cards and then going wild and then
paying it off before the interest hits
okay that's what i did
[Laughter]
i fixed a couple of things moved a
couple of credits around met him to
mcdonald's bing boom i'm a college
graduate
all right yeah
kippy let's talk about dect deck.com
dect.com we got a lot of people out
there that drives trucks yes uh
something i've always said is garbage
when you have one of those things over
the back of the truck the enclosed cab
the enclosed cab but if you got tools
and stuff like that you don't want to
take him in at night you don't want to
leave him out there somebody will grab
him this is where deck.com can help yeah
uh deck drawer system is weatherproof
and it protects and secures all your
stuff from mother nature who can be a
real mother you get it uh dec makes
organizing accessing everything you need
so much easier uh i got they they they
gave us one i sent it down to my stepdad
down there he's loving it oh buddy it's
like yeah you got you you got your drill
over here you got this over there your
nuts and bolts whatever you need you got
an extension cord always need an
extension and one thing i know he's
probably jazzed about made right here in
the good old u.s
it's so easy you go online you go hey i
got you know i got a ford f-150 what
year is it what's the length of the bed
they thought it all they got it all they
ship it right to the house bingo
boom boom boom snap it all in it's easy
peasy because if you got one of those
cabs man you're the an amber alert
you're the first guy getting pulled over
yeah if you're uh if you got if you work
construction plumbing heating and air
conditioning electrical you know we got
a lot of blue collar guys out there
deck.com they could benefit from
deck.com protect your stuff like we did
with dect get your decked drawer system
at deck.com garbage and get a free and
get free shipping that's deck.com
garbage for free shipping on your deck
drawer system deck.com garbage do
it do it kip let's talk about my fitness
pal
yeah i don't mean my fitness like you're
my pal you are my pal but i'm talking
about my fitness pal wait your fitness
pal anybody's my fitness pal no well it
could be yours fitness pal if you've got
a little cash on you you're gonna buy
some merch gang you gotta check out my
fitness pal if you're trying to lose
weight if you're trying to watch
calories uh absolutely fantastic yeah
the big man as you know you're starting
a health journey uh you're using this as
a tool you got the meal plan you're
walking right the whole nine yards and
the good thing about myfitnesspal it's
not a rigid uh diet plan instead you
gradually learn from personalized data
what works for you yeah right because
your your idea healthy is a little bit
different everybody's body is different
everybody's body reacts different ways
you know the keto the carbs the this to
that there's different things that are
good for different people and my fitness
pal can help you decide that yeah they
have a premium membership uh you get
tools expert guidance from you know
exercise uh experts doctors the whole
nine yards
um
and with myfitnesspal you're not going
at it alone you'll have access to a
guided daily workout and meal plans
written by dietitians exercise
scientists
uh plus support from other members who
share just sounds like a gym teacher
blowing a whistle uh myfitnesspal does
way more than count calories for a
limited time they're offering our
listeners three months of their premium
membership there you go we're free whoa
get up
if you're already a member no problem
you can still claim the offer these guys
are giving them holy cow yeah
uh get your paid member uh get your
premium membership by going to
garbage.myfitnesspal.com use promo code
garbage to get three months for free
three months that's
garbage.myfitnesspal
m-y-f-i-t-n-e-s-s-p-a-l-dot-com
code garbage
garbage.myfitnesspal.com now back to the
show
i like to dabble in low interest rate
credit cards yeah so what are your
interests what do you like to do
all right amex though
yeah classy classy what's the limit are
we talking i don't know
come on oh
i can look i bet it's like i bet it's
like 10 or 15 grand holy [ __ ]
and i always pay it in full every month
that's great what you got to do yeah
we're trying to get better we're trying
we're ours was
famously 500 and 200.
now i got a capital one card with a
jihad on it i got i got a memo card with
25. max out to the bridge those idiots
are giving money away
i can't put another nickel on this thing
but i don't know how to but the thing is
my parents did pay for my college and i
think that kind of sets you up a little
bit sure yeah i don't know what your
lives are yeah
yeah [ __ ] me up yeah my parents pay
for that [ __ ] too i'm still an idiot
okay yeah i'm bad with money and i don't
know how i keep finagling my that's why
comedy is great it's like every time i'm
down and i'm like oh my god what's gonna
happen i get a call and i'm like great
it's like kind of like drug dealer money
yeah i'll make it all back tomorrow i
don't care let's burn it yeah
yeah yeah
i spend it about to spend this cut you
know and then every time i'm about to
learn a lesson about like spending money
i just get a check yeah i'm like that's
great
you're not a saver are you a saver no
i'm really focused i think my next big
thing i'll try to like put it in a roth
ira or something i just said that i'm
getting my [ __ ] together january 1st
2022. no i love stuff and i love
spending money and it's really um i
can't stop and i thought the pandemic
would help me because i did get [ __ ]
over during the pandemic but it just
hasn't and i keep just going wild yeah
my new thing is i love sending uh
bottles of champagne to people wow
i love that
just out of the blue no it's like if
it's someone's birthday and i can't be
there i'll call the restaurant and i
love to send a bottle wow
that's like my favorite holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] joe pesci
that just blew my mind yeah that's the
classiest [ __ ] i've ever heard i think
right now it's nothing nothing it's zero
that's just no doubt that that canceled
out everything yeah you call up and you
say hey
um
so-and-so's there yeah send a nice what
are we talking about here um
it could be [ __ ] apple juice she's
still doing it the last time it was like
you know i'll just
couple hundred hundred no under 200.
under 200. yeah and then you tip and
then for a hotel if it's someone's hotel
you have to like fill out a third-party
authorization form or something it's
it's like more annoying but wait a
minute hold on hold on you're a friend
of yours is at a hotel for their
birthday you're not in the city you're
getting champagne sent to the room yeah
so when they walk in it's waiting there
yeah oh you're fun
that's a good time
wow
holy [ __ ]
that's a hoot man yeah i love it i'm
gonna start doing that to you
that's [ __ ] classy as [ __ ] i'm gonna
send you chocolates
i've done the move once or twice in my
life where somebody was there and i paid
the check and left i love that once or
twice i've had it was for my birthday it
was uh my brother's uh girlfriend was on
my 18th birthday or 21st birthday my
brother's girlfriend at the time we went
to la we landed
and she couldn't go so when we got there
there was a bottle of kettle one or
something they were like we like checked
in they knocked on the door i thought i
literally thought i was in the mob like
that's how that's how fancy i felt yeah
i don't think about it [ __ ] 20 years
ago you smacked the guy around what'd i
tell you about bringing this to the room
i usually i was like we don't have to
tip on this right that was taken care of
that's a bad move if you send someone a
bottle and don't tip on it
you got you've got yeah yes of course
that is close always 20 percent that is
classy yeah and you worked and you got
the service industry so you know what's
up yeah i just have fantasies like i
just want to go places and like paying
cash and just like tip hundreds of like
i just love that yeah it's nice it's a
good feeling so then i'll live that
fantasy like my therapist is always like
if you're doing it in a deficit you
shouldn't be doing it and all that stuff
but so like i'll like live large for a
few months
and then i'll be like oh no
and then
i got two checks this week so what
you're doing you're living in a deficit
i do the exact same yeah i just want to
have fun
yeah it's a good time that's great yeah
descending champagne god damn it that's
[ __ ] old school yeah i love it or if
like someone's sad
what's in a bad mood i'll like uh i'll
postmates them some milk bar like i'll
figure i like to i like to send people
[ __ ] that's a lot of fun well one last
question
miss traeger what it's last about no no
how will you have it sent over to the
table will you say what would you like
me to say well they go over and say hey
lisa wanted to
couldn't be here yeah i do need the
credit there's no secret bottles of
champagne being sent i like that yeah no
i'd like them to know it's from me do
you tell them verbatim over the phone
what you want them to say or just say
tell them it's from lisa yeah i'm just
like tell them happy birthday have fun
wish i was there i don't know damn see
that's how crazy you are you want to
give back you want to make the waiter
give a speech
you're giving them sides
run down a couple of them imdb credits
stewie yeah
oh you're nuts oh holy [ __ ] that i'm
[ __ ] blown away wow yeah i love to do
i love room service i just i definitely
um
yeah when was the last time you had a
massage
um
like november 2019. wow years ago yeah
that's not really my thing i only do it
on vacation or like that's not really my
thing you're gonna have service this
weekend though
yeah yeah for sure i love eating
breakfast like room service breakfast
and i use the towels at the hotel or the
uh the robes at the hotel you getting to
one of them i did there were no robes
but if there's a robe i'll wear it okay
absolutely have you ever used i'm
petrified of those and sorry room
service i've bought in a robe at a nice
hotel before it was honestly one of the
sexiest it's like um the robe is nice
outside but inside it was a terry cloth
so it's because i hate
i hate drawing i air dry like it really
bothers me it's just like i don't want
i'm you know i have to take my time and
so this is a robe with a towel on the
inside but like so nice material on the
outside and i love it do you have nice
towels and things like that at your home
no not really they're fine okay like bed
bath and beyond okay yeah
target
brush your teeth in the shower yeah but
i have one i have a toothbrush on each
place
okay at the sink and then yeah so
whatever i'm in the mood for okay
what does this mean that doesn't really
help you yeah it has a it has a cupboard
i mean it has a cover on it is it trashy
to brush your teeth in the shower yeah i
just don't think it's fantastic i do it
all it's how i brush my teeth it's trash
why
uh
you get to stay in the hot water long
you're just like having another time
biological it's germs it's yeah there's
it's like
you know there's germs everywhere i know
but like your [ __ ] is exposed while
you're like cleaning your mouth it's
just listen
there's mildew yeah but what if you're
naked when you brush your teeth at the
same time i do i do it i i agree with
you i do it you're preaching to the
choir i know but i just don't think it
means anything but you're telling me it
is i mean you are the people you base
the show on it
and toby cut that
i don't know who this russian broad is
but i think she's taking secrets
i got a saboteur in here
yes it is garbage to brush your teeth in
the shower do you pee in the shower
also garbage yeah yes but i do it as
well you know why because one time
that's the reason you're brushing your
teeth in the same place
but madonna one time on david letterman
said she pees in the shower and if
madonna does it i was like i'm going to
do it for the rest of my life and i
don't care i can see that that's my
excuse for him tells me to stop being in
the shower
i like it hmm um i am easily influenced
by celebrities
have you ever ruined a surprise party
no no no i love surprises okay
when was the last time you went to an
outlet store
oh
off sacks nordstrom rack
i not in gear i don't know okay no no no
i guess i'll go to a i've been to a tj
maxx but i have spending issues and i
picked up all this stuff and then i
didn't buy it and it was like a big
moment in my life but that happened
that's like 97 of people does most of
your spending online will you order
things instead i go to the store uh yeah
i'll do that okay
and something we missed what was the
typical traeger family vacation
road oh this is garbage okay we would um
take meetings for times this
wait you would do the meetings we would
do timeshare meetings for vacation road
trips oh my god as a family yeah
yeah damn yeah
no bottles of champagne there where we
where are we talking no i might uh my
dad would like we would eat on the road
but my dad would bring a cooler in a
food that he brought on his own and he
refused to eat restaurant food and he
would eat what he brought in the cooler
really your dad didn't eat restaurant
food no cause he's always like your mom
makes it but i hate that he hate they
just like don't understand going out to
eat what's your what would be one of
your mom's specialties everything she's
like incredible but i would say like i
love her like baby pancakes russian a
little bit but she makes like uh what we
call him video cable like from scratch
she makes the dough the potato all of it
damn listening
yeah she great borscht really yeah
she'll cut pulling herself out of this
yeah she's going to get to the judge
yeah
my mom makes potatoes you don't care
does anyone have any sour cream on them
uh i didn't even say filet mignon she
said pierogies and you're [ __ ] you
got pierogies
i just yeah i love
um everything she makes but they make
their own jams farmers cheese like they
make [ __ ] so where would you go on these
vacations um the wisconsin dells
uh we went to tennessee one year and we
got oh the wisconsin dells is like vegas
but not like one year i was over 18
because in wisconsin i went bungee
jumping i fed a giraffe we went mini
golfing it's kind of like a wild place
damn they have a big water park
okay that's wild usually
where would you go and have to hear this
the pitch the sales pitch would it be in
chicago somewhere no you would at the
vacation so like in the dells i remember
taking a meeting i don't remember i
don't remember the tendency
you acted like your agent called oh yeah
we're gonna take a meeting buy some
goober in a red vest
i'll be upstairs here in this about this
two bedroom they got i i would say the
the dells is a similar vibe to like
going down the shore here it's like a
very common see that's where i'm
confused and i apologize because
normally when i think of time shares
it's like down to florida we did that
yeah well we went to florida with and
then my mom worked with this guatemalan
family and so all of them and us got a
giant van and we all drove to disney
together for and we did meetings from
chicago well i'm sorry i did meetings
yeah along the way
no just like in florida and then
when you do 2015 in nashville we gotta
we got a boogie
don't even buy you lunch
holy [ __ ] and then you're not taking
that
i know
the only classy thing is i'll give it
the champagne is very classy very yeah
back is stacked against her man in a van
on a family vacation with another family
yeah yikes who's driving the the mate
the patriarchs
the fathers yeah okay
i don't know what patriarch
i was like oh yeah i got one of them
it's kind of political i stayed away
from it
let's go back to the toothbrush
a family show
we would drive to new york niagara falls
um that's crazy what else did we drive
to we went to saint louis gross um
i saint louis is my lead
he went on a vacation to arkansas
and then finally because
me and my parents went to the dominican
republic but i was so
like a dumb [ __ ] teen and i ruined
their i was like a [ __ ] like i feel
really i was going to ask you next
question i demanded my own room and so i
got my own room in the dominican
republic and was still a [ __ ] to them
stole their credit card i had my
sister's fake id went to the casino
and like just was the making casinos are
a good time though
i was in one about a month ago
[ __ ] 90 million pesos flying around
um but i was just like mean to them you
ruined the vacation i ruined the
vacation and i i'm only working hard so
i can make it up to them but i did i was
a [ __ ] but we had a so that was like
our that was fun and then my sister god
bless her now she takes my parents she
took him to israel into italy oh nice
and she took them to mexico a couple
times like so she takes them on all the
trips so that's great
yeah because they're very annoying and
so she's doing like a real mitzvah for
the family that's awesome yeah that's
what it's all about
um how often do you check your mail ugh
i hate it i try not right i try not to i
throw it in a thing but my friend came
and helped me organize and i have a
thing that i can put it in
but i don't like to check them out i'm
still today anxiety box man every time i
turn that key i'm like someone
something's going to jump out of here
and tell them i owe you five grand but
you know what made sense to me you said
something one day when you were like
yeah i haven't checked in four months
and you're like if something was coming
off it would have already came they
would have called me yeah the cable
would not be on the indictment would be
already handed not being cuffs right now
yeah guys and windbreakers would show up
if that was the case so i'm getting
better and better with it i just give it
a [ __ ] about it at all i check it maybe
once every two weeks and then just
immediately if i'll go i'll just do this
yeah and if there's not like a card from
like my [ __ ] nana or whatever i just
throw it all the way check sometimes
there are secret checks that reminds me
but like yeah i just hate tasks i don't
like tasks at all it sucks [ __ ] sucks
elaborate on that you don't like tasks
at all no i just get overwhelmed by
simple tasks
checking the mail check in the mail
kills me i can't like doing paperwork
filling out a for i just like um i can't
do it do you have a clean you have a
cleaning person that you're i am just
starting to i'm going to have my first
per she's coming november 9th lily
shout out to lily simon what's going on
into a buzzer and you keep it pretty
tight no i actually i have a lot of
problems and then my best friend
you don't say
no my best friend a few weeks ago flew
from new york to la to help me organize
decorate and clean the apartment nice
and so now that i have it at a nice
place i got uh my girl lily and would
you say you might have porter's
tendencies or no yeah the whole family
does
yeah in all different ways and so
um but i'm trying to end it and so i did
get rid of a lot of like i was like
crying getting rid of dresses it was
like okay so [ __ ] up
it's weird but my best friend is like a
good person and she really
yeah she did it the volunteer to go do
that with somebody
a lot yeah she's really good at it and
she's helped me set like one time i was
out of town and she went and cleaned my
room while i was gone as a surprise like
she just uh really helps me you should
do that to me sometimes but yeah i just
have lots of outfits but now send me
some champagne sometimes
yeah i do buy her luxurious presents at
all times really yeah like i've gotten
or what's the most you dropped on a on a
present for somebody i would say like
400. pretty good it's nice did you buy
something the first time in comedy you
got a big check did you buy something
stupid is there a big dumpster
wave runner
[Music]
a timeshare at the dells a 16 passenger
van
oh my god i don't know
i have no idea i don't remember
okay but i for sure bought stuff i know
after the degenerates i went to celine
dion the next day and we went to nobu
for
dinner love that yeah yeah and then
celine dion and that was fun
what about in the bedroom what's the
sleeping situation how many pillows is
there a fan on you what's the story fans
four pillows four you're using four
people have a ceiling fan or one on like
the table i have like a cute i have a i
forgot it's a cute bra it's a cute fan i
have a cute fan okay
you could put me in a room and i could
never come up with what a cute fan
unfortunately no matter how cute the fan
is it's still garbage really fans are
garbage garbage i'm a fan guy i want a
fake face i'm a fan guy and i have like
once i got my ac
yeah i have an ac thing that fan fans
too sometimes i have it all open i yeah
i want and i want no and i yeah and i
sleep with uh shows i want to show on
you sleep with the show on okay you
gotta have the tv on yeah how many
pillows under the head is there one
between the legs are you holding one
what's the positioning no they're all up
top oh really yeah oh that's not too bad
an aristocrat yeah
but that i love
you know that more pillows around the
body would be
crashier oh great okay yeah they're all
up top but i lo i would my dream is to
have more pillows
i always want more but not for using
just for decorations no no no no to use
them i want like hotel like
you know i just want to smell
i want a wall of dil like pillows but
they would all remain where the pillows
are supposed to stay is what i'm asking
yes okay yeah that's classy yeah i have
decorative pillows on the couch
okay
okay pull out couch
not a pull out okay it's classy it's
leather it's cute actually the couch is
all right it's actually a it's an
amazing couch my other couch uh yeah
it's really nice i got it for 150 bucks
though my friends yes okay never mind
take that but it's nice as [ __ ] no you
bought a used couch i don't care how did
you know they asked that that was what
i thought she said she got it for 150
yeah cruising there for a minute no it's
so cute people always compliment it
basically like all the moms in my life
they're always on um the mom groups and
you can get everything you want on a mom
facebook group they're just um it's
really connected so when i was moving
back to la um they just went on the mom
group and i got this couch and i love it
are these well-off people in these
groups um yeah i would say yes so that's
pretty la it wasn't it is a beautiful
couch
basically the mom is like mike the mom
okay
we met the mom she had like a beautiful
home and she was just like my family
wants one of the else couches to lounge
sectional yeah
okay i get it yeah i mean i yeah sure
but i have a corn stool that's really
cute cornstarch yeah it's like a stool
but it's made out of resin and it looks
like a corn like a piece of corn with a
little bite out of it and it's so cute
okay sounds pretty trendy that's trash
i don't know about that it's art [ __ ]
yeah it's it's designer it's a stool
well it's like yeah
but it is a piece of corn it's okay it's
really cute it looks like an art piece
not something you bought coming out of a
cracker barrel no okay all right
i actually was sold out at the store
that i like to support tell me it's not
one of these that's exactly what it is
oh my god that's trash what giant corn
stool it's so cute
come
i bought it directly from the
manufacturer because i loved it so much
and the store i bought it from
washington artistic
i mean it is an expensive stool i'll
give you that 250. that's a lot for us
that ain't no man a i can tell you that
right now
it looks like a mold for dentures or
something
it is cool it's pretty it's cool yeah i
get you it's it is that is already for
sure it looks like it's still trash
[ __ ] up at a mini golf course
all right i like pined after it for
years it is cool i will give you that
my wife was like hey we get this i'd be
like sure why don't you wear a ring
whoa
i don't know why you're attacking me
right now but we're having a nice time
sitting here sitting on you and your
family for an hour also the guns turn on
me
all right i like the stool jesus keep
going jesus christ lady what the [ __ ] um
i just don't i never
not for you it's not for me and she
doesn't care it was like when i would
hold the mic i would hear it and feel it
yeah and then i just took it off and
also i bought it on amazon for like nine
bucks the day before
um she doesn't wear one either okay
what nothing on that come on well it was
fine if she didn't wear one yeah of
course
anywho i do make a stay in the kitchen
the whole time
wait a minute i keep making silences
happen okay no it happens all the time
but you know what i do spend money on
that my like i do buy art i have um i
buy art everybody aren't from a coffee
shop
i want to start maybe in my early 20s
that's garbage that's why maybe when i
was at a bar i would
no but i buy art you ever buy anything
at the salon
like products or hair products yeah of
course that's classy i feel like is it
that was to me rich guy [ __ ] like
growing up like we did we had to keep
that weird comb that they sold at the
barbershop that's not a hair salon
that thing that looks like it's for dogs
i don't [ __ ] with that that's a cone i
always hold on it's like a it literally
it's like a
oval and it's got a bunch of little
teeth it looks like a brush it's like
it's like a oh okay it's a little bit i
don't know what it's for they've never
sold them even you could go to the same
barber for a hundred years and it's
still the same three sitting no that's
classy to buy products like that yeah
that's real that's that's
yeah i'm getting my hair done on
thursday
very nice tip
20 minimum always and then if it's
around the holidays maybe than a little
more yeah okay
all right you're getting that done here
yeah it's i i miss my girl so that's why
i have great like so much gray hair
right now and then i'll see her on
thursday okay so you got a spot here
yeah it's pretty good i haven't found an
la like
place yet for really yeah i've been go
i've i went to what i actually went to a
woman and she's really cool billy eilish
goes there so this was exciting she was
a waitress at the irvine improv for 18
years whoa how [ __ ] cool is that so
she had all these stories and it was
really fun that's great so maybe i'd go
back so i don't know i just haven't
connected with anyone in la yet okay but
i have a tattoo shop now in l.a and i
love that
no disney tattoos right absolutely not
okay but i have other trade i have
snoopy
okay that's not great i have a lot of
trademarks like what i have the utts
girl
i'll give you that's potato chips that's
a fine establishment
hey
they each their own fans one step
forward two steps back
but that step forward really hits home
yeah i got the pringles guy
if you haven't had if you have a tattoo
of mr t on your back
you're in no and then i have the red hot
chili peppers and that's like my most
shameful tattoo oh man that's that two
steps back it comes
it's upsetting what song do you have
like a no it's the [ __ ] logo i know
but like what song got you into it
um californication
i loved other side by love by the way
and then i got into all their old stuff
too obviously i became obsessed but like
for the record the red hot chili peppers
are [ __ ] awesome okay they're awesome
the tattoo they don't age that man i
disagree californication was it was a
landmark cobblestone i love yeah you
just went underwater
you sounded like sonic when he went
underwater
so you have the
design right the asterisk looking thing
yeah and it's just giant the moment i
walked out of the shop i was like how
big is it it's like this big
on my ankle it's really big
it's probably the worst one i have um
all right um never eat any food in the
subway like if you've ever gotten
churros or anything down in the subway
will you will you pull that move
i haven't but i would okay all right
it's okay maybe i i bought fruit snacks
from like the vendors
okay what the [ __ ] got to help you back
you gotta help the basketball team come
on
these kids are out there working hard
can't save the speech just give me a
couple of gushers no yeah i can't say no
to like a gummy you can't no never
especially those yeah the little kids
yeah um
at any point did your family use colored
toilet paper no okay
do you prefer the jazz or live version
of any hit songs
i don't think love
no jazz i don't think so i like words
okay
um do you frequent hibachi restaurants
no no
actually when i was yeah no i i was at
one once and before the food i was like
we gotta get out of here when we left
really yeah we were my friend i went to
mexico and we were like sitting there
and i was like i'm not sitting with all
these people i was like i'm out of here
yeah yeah i can't any doll houses
growing up no okay
can you name any pets that are instagram
famous
yeah i must i follow a kit of pets oh my
god i follow baby gray i don't know if i
know
what's baby gray oh the thank you mama
his mom makes beautiful oh yeah a little
kid every time you hear my mom oh like
it's a cute little kid
that mom can throw down too oh yeah
she's all over the place too all
different types of quizzes everything
fantastic and so much yeah it's like i
just am obsessed with him so um
yeah he's grumpy cat
grumpy cat but he's dead i don't know if
that matters
rest in peace to a real one bubbles
[Laughter]
all right um all right i like animals oh
well teddy the shetland oh the shetland
pony i love how could you not you know
there's one shetland you're gonna follow
can be seated you know michelle i can't
believe you mentioned billy eilish
before him
that's crazy
i got a name jump let's do it right
she's so l.a
i like johnny the frumpy ferret
stevie the schnauzer
um
all right we got michelle collins met
teddy the shetland recently i don't know
if you know her but i don't know anybody
in that shell collins hosted my uh
gotham comedy live that i did nice
channel 837 check it out
um
all right i have two from patreon uh so
when you guys sign up for patreon we
will answer your garbage question on the
air it's just the best way to do it
uh this one's from tyler's awesome
self-given name i presume uh have you
ever crossed a highway on foot to get
somewhere
no but i've watched it there's no way
that
like a bridge under a highway i just did
that this weekend to get to dunkin
donuts but
wait what do you mean yeah a lot of
times especially like i haven't like are
you talking crossing lanes of a highway
i have never crossed
that is dangerous and i would not do
that
this is where she tightens up i was
dangerous and i will never break a
pedestrian law ever unless my skirt
comes off
or whatever the second offense was
why did you hold on why did you walk
under a bridge to get to a dunkin donuts
i was at a hotel and i wanted some
coffee in an egg and cheese croissant
what was it was there like a path like a
sidewalk or you just like went rolling
with the trees making a lot of sense
okay she gets me every time
because let me tell you something those
bacon egg and cheese croissants are
thrown down in dunkin donuts ain't too
shabby no i don't know what they do but
the egg and cheese croissant dunkin
donuts that's my favorite you know what
it's the croissant croissants are just
the greatest delivery system wait when
we were in
did you get i got at the hotel they had
an everything croissant and it was one
of the best things i've had in my life
really it was so good it's all right
wait she could be like i killed my
sister you're like what she's like on my
way to get a okay you're throwing me off
here hold on
god damn you redeemed yourself
i do like a nice cheesesteak
but it's not our fault like when you're
on the road and you're staying in these
trash ass towns you're going to walk
through weird things
that's of course that's what i was the
every time i've crossed the highway yeah
has been for comedy because you're like
the [ __ ] you know ramada on the side
of some turnpike what was under the
bridge
is that what you wanted
that's it we gotta close with that
that's right yeah give me the patreon
question i never want this to end well
we have we only have one more uh this is
from hugh g rection
[Laughter]
uh who curses more your mom or your dad
no one really curses wow
i mean when they would fight they would
say [ __ ] to each other but like i that's
not really the vibe i could probably
curse more than anybody yeah i i've
taken it terrible
i curse do you curse to your mom will
you curse like at like not at your mom
be like can you [ __ ] believe this
yeah now yeah as an adult and my friends
like when i talk to my mom on the phone
because it's russian russian and then
i'll be like you [ __ ] believe this
[ __ ] and then i'll like go back to
speaking normal are there any fun
russian insults like this guy's a son of
a shoe or like a pig dog or something
i'm sure
for something but i
i don't really know where the [ __ ]
swears or like um what
these two
we had a meeting before the show
your suggestions were so scrupled what'd
you say
what
wait what is it like sheep thief yeah
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you that's
like old world that's like old country
[ __ ] like yeah what the [ __ ] man yeah
how are you not getting this you're a
comedian
he's still got donkeys on a brain
got them tater tots dancing around in my
head i apologize
um continue no i don't not really yeah i
feel bad these patreon i have nothing to
tell these people no no no it's funny
it's fine i like blob and that's like um
like like a
[ __ ] sloppy jerk you know like i got
one right now like like flagrant what's
that like a like a chauvinist i don't
know like jalob is like
you're messy yeah is that where schlub
comes from maybe maybe probably she's
probably that face-off
there's like bad words and they just
make me uncomfortable honestly i don't
like swearing in russian okay i don't
know what it is yeah no fair enough
right i get it yeah um well we still
have to wait for the official
uh board to come in from next door but
uh
i'm gonna go out on a limb here
the kid's trash oh
golden time golden trap but with like
layers with like very classy yeah yeah i
mean the champagne thing
i'm forever changed from hearing that
i'm gonna do that for sure i'm doing
that as soon as you get off from
somebody's champagne
i don't know who it is
it could be you could be you
oh man yeah i like that i like sending a
thank you card i'm like into that would
you say you're classy now
um i don't think i'm like a snob but i'd
like doing nice things but i can like um
do not nice things you're just under a
bridge for this yeah i was gonna say the
end of the bridge dunkin donuts thing
that was this weekend right it was it
was all right but and i guess i'm
staying at a shitty hotel right now
that's not really my favorite but when i
was in chicago two weeks ago i stayed at
the drake hotel
that was like a childhood dream of mine
and so that was really exciting and then
i met like a former nfl player was
sitting next to me at the bar and that
was really fun but i was like this is my
childhood dream
his name was joshua perry oh it's nobody
famous no well he has a championship
ring with ohio state and he's an
announcer for the big ten network and he
obviously has dreams of being an
announcer he played three years in the
nfl okay it was exciting for me john
elway i can tell you that no but no um
he had a louis vuitton wallet so i knew
he had money so that's my next big thing
with this new money we were making
a nice wallet i knew we had money that's
that that's trash why he must have cash
on it yeah well you're at the drake
you're drinking a martini it was only i
had a man like i yeah i was like because
then he goes out of manhattan yeah
that's not true
i love a maker's manhattan hat and there
it is were you were you there in town on
business i was doing comedy yeah okay
and you were staying at the hotel and
you went down had a drink at the bar
yeah and then he got a reuben and it
looked good so then i asked for the menu
he's out to lunch again the [ __ ] man
that's pretty classy i look good so then
i got the menu he was like
it's also so funny the way you two
communicate it's like you're both from
different worlds and like she'll say
something and you have no idea what the
[ __ ] he's talking about it sounded so
nice and sophisticated it said it's
before the reuben yeah before the proof
then i saw some cheesesteak egg rolls
a couple of pot stickers but yeah you
know it's a 20 something dollar reuben
oh yeah no for sure it's an overpriced
reuben okay
ladies and gentlemen i didn't get the
reuben uh but anyways so then he was
like what are you gonna get to eat and
then he's like oh that's weird i have to
stay here for work for 15 weeks in the
fall i go sir i'm not i'm no fool you're
clearly working football yeah damn 15
weeks thinking i went to drake hotel
yeah but he was like it's kind of dusty
here we were at a nicer one he was like
shocked it was my childhood dream i was
like
oh that's even better lisa traeger
ladies and gentlemen
thanks for having me buddy what do you
have coming up let them let the gang
know when will this come out
uh next week oh great sunday i think
i'll be insane a week from today i'll be
in san francisco the friday saturday
after thanksgiving um at the punch line
cool
i don't know it's like 26 27 28
something there so i'll be there
um and that's all i have yeah and that's
messed up in svu podcast
check it out gang kids
i'm excited to be in san francisco yeah
i hope people come that'll be fun go out
gang go check her out check her out
extremely funny fantastic kippy what do
you got uh guys our live shows uh we
have new if you're listening to this
today we have new york uh
tomorrow if there's tickets left get
those and then we're gonna [ __ ] go we
have upstate we're gonna be in syracuse
connecticut and albany get those [ __ ]
tickets and then we're launching a bunch
of dates for 2022 get involved it's
gonna be fun gang we love you we'll see
you next week